nous sommes ici donc aux 500 3 qui est
le centre d'entrepreneuriat de
l'institut d'optique graduate school
dans lequel on développe des programmes
en faveur de l'entrepreneuriat de la
stimulation de l'entreprenariat et
l'innovation chez les jeunes
particulièrement donc des étudiants
entrepreneurs et qu'on plonge dans un
écosystème composé de start-up
technologiques innovantes pour ces
jeunes entrepreneurs ces startups joue
un petit peu le rôle de grand frère
les coaches les accompagnent leur donne
des conseils
donc ils peuvent les rencontrer et avoir
des modèles de développement
je dirige une société qui s'appelle
tematis toute société il ya des locaux
ici pour pour plusieurs raisons c'est
d'abord c'est que je donne quelques
cours de marketing des technologies à
l'institut d'optique et le fait d'être
présent d'être sur place nous facilite
les choses mais nous pas nous a permis
par exemple d'embaucher une jeune fille
il ya deux ans qui viendrait si vous
avez des ressources clés dans ce lieu il
y a notamment des salles mutualisés
dédiés à la créativité à l'organisation
de forums de conférence où se retrouvent
les étudiants entrepreneurs des experts
qui viennent justement aider ces
étudiants
il ya également un photonique fab lab
qui permettent de mutualiser des
ressources technologiques ricky est
ouvert aux étudiants entrepreneurs et
aux entreprises en développement
j'ai été diplômé de sup optique en 2010
où j'ai suivi la filière innovation
entrepreneurs à la suite de quoi pendant
deux ans j'ai travaillé à l'étranger
et puis on a monté notre boîte être
bâtiment 503 ça nous permet de vivre
dans un écosystème où il ya mais
beaucoup de gens dans le domaine de
l'optique
donc c'est assez facile de discuter avec
des experts en plus de quoi on a
également accès aux faiblesses ce qui
nous aide beaucoup dans notre
développement
prototype laisse le 503 est un des lieux
innovant du campus paris saclay et qui a
l'ambition d'assurer des connexions
entre les différents publics et
personnes qui vivent sur ce campus donc
entre les chercheurs les industries les
start up et les étudiants dans
l'objectif de favoriser
l'entrepreneuriat la création
d'entreprise la valorisation de la
recherche